what is up everybody it's 414 anime here
for anime uproar and I'm back at it
again to discuss the latest crazy
chapter of One Piece just want to say a
quick thank you for all of the get well
soon comments for gozen in the last
video it was really appreciated and you
guys are absolute Legends unfortunately
our boy is still unwell so you have me
for another week I hope you don't mind
so this chapter had some very
interesting things happen within it for
us to look at so make sure you stay
tuned for that now if you do enjoy these
one piece videos on the channel you know
what to do yes smash that like button if
you haven't already make this the video
that you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece chapter reviews and updates
and now without further Ado let's jump
into It spoilers and all
chapter 1066 was entitled the will of
Ohara which as we know O'Hara is the
birthplace and origins of Nico Robin
located in the West Blue an island that
was inhabited by mainly archaeologists
that was destroyed by a buster call a
buster call being the ultimate form of
military attack used by none other than
the Marines the cover story for this
chapter shows the German ships returning
home as it reads German 66's are an
emotionless Excursion Germans return
home now into the chapter itself we
start off with the conversation Shaka
was having with Frankie Robin Nami Sanji
and usob where he dropped that big
reveal about the past Frankie responds
to the bombshell of knowledge dropped by
saying what are you talking about that
once in the past this futuristic city
existed Shaka goes on to say in the
world of archeology there was once a man
who risked his life to find out about
that Kingdom then he found a machine in
a certain place that had a manufacture
date which matched the theory he had in
mind this to me is a very vague reveal
here in the way he says it you know it's
like he's still keeping his cards close
to his chesting saying yeah a man did
this and found this in this place you
know it's telling the guys what happened
without telling them exactly what
happened if that makes sense Robin asks
if the machine was produced during the
void Century to which Shaka turns around
to her and asks how much do you know
about that and I like how this seemed to
stop Shaka in his tracks a bit here when
I saw the panel it just made me think
that by hearing the void Century he
instantly stopped and turned his head
turning his head in a saw of either
disbelief or manner that caught him off
guard by just how much they knew about
this as if you know they knew more than
he thought they did Nami says Robin did
you know something about that and Shaka
goes on to talk about how he remembered
that it was a painful story he says that
22 years ago your birthplace was
destroyed with a buster call from the
Navy and that he thinks that the reason
it got destroyed was because O'Hara knew
about the existence of that Kingdom the
next bit of information that Shaka drops
I thought was really interesting as he
goes on to say during the void Century
there was once a highly Advanced
civilization that existed the history
about the battle was between a certain
Kingdom and 20 kingdoms the winners were
the 20 kingdoms they founded the world
government that the world knows today to
make sure that nobody carried on that
Kingdom's ideology they raised the
Kingdom from existence now I love this
drop of information here as it gives us
a little more insight into just what was
going on all that time ago during the
void century is this saying that it was
an all-out gang up on this one highly
Advanced Kingdom or did it take 20
kingdoms just to take this one ancient
Kingdom down due to its highly
technologically advanced ways I'm
looking forward to finding out more on
that now do we also think that emu Sama
was behind this as well interesting
thoughts here so let us know what you
think in the comment section below the
guys react wildly to this as to be
expected Sanji says wait a minute
vagapunk then those people who knew
about it they to which Sanji is cut off
by Shaka who boldly says yes they've
been obliterated Sanji does ask the
question then why are you talking about
this so easily which I think is a very
valid question in my opinion but there
is still a lot to Shaka and the
vagapongs that we do not know yet of
course I do like usopp's mini
predictable breakdown here throughout
the conversation it kind of gives us a
little breather from the heavy situation
before we go back in and are of course
hit with more so Shaka continues and
poses the question to Robin that if
O'Hara was erased because of this Theory
then does that mean that the government
had acknowledged that the theory was
indeed the truth again I think this is a
very valid question in my opinion but
the way in which he poses said question
and how he talks about the situation
really seems to not go down well with
the crew Robin especially as she says
who do you think you are talking about
us like that the researchers in O'Hara
made a theory from researching various
important documents do you think the
government would hear it from a powerful
person like you to which Shaka says that
no I'm similar to you even if I work
with the government I'll be obliterated
myself if I were to talk about it Robin
asks him how do you know about about
that Kingdom as all the books Ohara had
gathered from around the world had been
and Shaka interrupts her to say that the
will of O'Hara still lives he goes on to
explain that the once Ohara was famous
worldwide for his knowledge and that it
got destroyed in a single night albeit
for a lone girl as its savior which is
of course our Robin he continues to say
that the world government had labeled
them as an evil scholar group that were
plotting to take over the world this is
of course one of many times that the
world government has used its power to
manipulate the truth in their favor so
that the world follows them if they want
to cover something up they will easily
do so and those that know the truth
behind these lies and cover-ups will be
dealt with swiftly and without mercy so
Shaka continues to say that he actually
visited O'Hara months after the incident
and that the island was now nothing more
than a burning field he he also reveals
that he was an old acquaintance with
Professor Clover The Scholar leader
which of course shocked Robin Shaka
tells us more of clover in that he was
very interested in the void Century he
knew him as an adventurer that gathered
books from all around the world and that
Clover had actually been captured and
imprisoned 10 times by the Navy but
despite that he still went on to become
known as the famous number one
archaeologist in the world Professor
Clover was the founder of O'Hara as he
had gathered every scholar in O'Hara and
the island became known as The Sanctuary
for archaeologists his end was a tragic
thing for such a talented man Shaka
continued to say that he couldn't
believe what had happened when he
arrived at the island the Marines had
even burned down the tree of knowledge a
tree that was over 5 000 years old and
the hub for archaeologists from all
around the world now one thing to a note
from this panel is just how odd looking
his silhouette is it's like an oversized
pineapple attached to a body kind of
classic one piece character design
anyway Shaka continues to say that he
found a lake in the central area where
he found a lot of bugs drowning even
though the island was on fire and being
destroyed by the Buster call the
scholars still did everything they could
to protect and save the knowledge that
they had gathered true archaeologists
and absolute Legends big big props to
them now the next panel is one that I
really enjoyed it's off Shaka and he
says the clueless soldiers saw it but
they didn't realize its value it was a
great victory for O'Hara when I saw it
my tears wouldn't stop flowing see I
really liked this panel because you
could just feel the pain and frustration
that he felt for the people of O'Hara
and at the same time the anger towards
the ones who had done this to the
innocent people of the Island including
his old acquaintance however at the same
time there was again a frustrated Joy to
the fact that they managed to save the
information that the Marines tried to
destroy through these bugs sometimes a
panel just makes you feel deep in your
stomach exactly what that character is
feeling at that given time and this one
gave me that so back to the chapter and
this sends Robin straight into a
flashback of that time when her mother
was urging her to live it's a very
touching goodbye between the two and one
we have seen in many a story to be fair
but there is just something about a
parent putting themselves on the line in
order for their child to survive that it
really just hits you know Robin's mother
says there are things she needs to do
here Robin history is an asset for
Humanity we shouldn't give up on the
future that you'll be living in massive
statement right there and yes hit me in
the Phils Robin tells Shaka that O'Hara
did try to expose that Kingdom just as
he had predicted and asks if he knew
what happened to the books that the
archaeologists had thrown into the lake
Shaka says that he wanted to bring them
to punk Hazard but his plea fell on
death ears he continues but we get to
see the events of 22 years ago when he
went to O'Hara a month after that buster
call we see that it was the Giants who
were saving the books from the lake
before we see a very interesting person
standing on the Rocks calling out to
vagapunk that person is none other than
Monkey D dragon
vegapong asks why he is hit which Dragon
replies by saying that's my line before
making a comment on the size of
vegapunk's head and yet this panel shows
us vagapunk here properly and he does
look really weird like the head is so
huge and alien-like that it reminded me
of that Roger character from the
American Dad show or the Cantina Band
from Star Wars definitely let us know
what your first impressions of his
appearance were in the comments
interestingly the panel also shows us
the ages of both men at this time with
vegapunk being 43 and dragon being 33.
now back to the conversation we find out
that Dragon was also an acquaintance of
Professor clovers and you can tell that
he is also affected by what had happened
to him as he says that I knew him when
he was a tough guy who traveled the
world to label him as someone who tried
to destroy the world is unbelievable
that must be some important manipulation
he continues to ask very if he is
interested in those giants Dragon
confirms that he himself checked in with
them earlier and they are not Bandits
they came from elbaf and that they know
the value of the books he also says that
their Captain is a strange guy with
bandages covering his body the pair's
conversation continues and it's pretty
interesting Dragon says that you guys
from the world government didn't know
their value so I'm glad they didn't get
destroyed vagabong tries to reply by
saying wait I'm not before he is cut off
by Dragon who says I'm tired of hearing
it even you became that the government
lap dog even though we The Liberation
invited you you rejected it vagapong
tells Dragon to stop being ridiculous
and that even with his wisdom and
Technology what can your poor Army make
ouch Dragon responds by saying that
vegapunk is just as blunt a guy as he
used to be no joke there that was a a
low blow statement it is interesting
information there knowing the The
Liberation Army had tried to enlist
vagapunk into their ranks so vagapon
continues to say that the world
government is a massive organization
especially the Navy there are a lot of
people who can understand me don't lose
your objective dragon dragon was
understandably angered by the O'Hara
incident and goes on to say that in the
name of Justice they beat up the
powerless researchers with violence just
because they had an unreasonable opinion
I will make an army that can fight it
vegapunk is like wait you you're the guy
that despises violence Dragon continues
to say just see it vagapunk I will
change the world I won't let Clover's
death and The Willow though horror go in
vain we jump back to our time and Shaka
tells us that that year Dragon along
with ivankoff and Kumar established the
Revolutionary Army and shocked the world
now it was awesome to see that it was
this incident on O'Hara that was the
Catalyst for Dragon forming the
Revolutionary Army of course it does
sound like Dragon did have something
going on already at the time but this
incident on O'Hara really lit the fire
under him to go out and make his move on
the world government it was also really
interesting to find out that Dragon was
once an acquaintance of Professor Clover
which obviously made this instant all
the more personal for him now Robin Nami
Sanji Frank and Usopp are all
understandably shocked by this news and
Shaka continues to say that the books of
O'Hara did not fall into the
government's hands because he was very
interested in them he went to albaf in
secret and they let him read all of the
documents in other words all the
information Shaka had read about horror
and the secrets of the world are all now
stored inside of his head for
progressing his research Robin says to
vagapunk that the name of the Giant's
Captain is Saul right to which he says
yes he is hiding now and no one will
disclose his whereabouts Robin says
thank you Dr vagapunk please don't let
O'Hara's battle go in vain he says that
he is an ally for every scholar and that
it is his nature as a researcher before
saying now follow me there is something
I want to show you this is awesome news
to here that Seoul also survived the
incident and being frozen by kuzan not
only did he let Robin Escape but he let
Soul live as well glad to hear that so
we then move on to Luffy's group who are
with the Rusted ancient robot we saw at
the end of the last chapter Luffy says
there is no place to ride it Chopper and
Chopper says oh I see so it's an
automatic type they then begin to shout
out commands or passwords to the robot
in the hopes that it will get it moving
my favorite being move robonosuke then
we're all shocked as the robot explodes
we then see vagapunk who screams please
help me it still failed someone please
help me while I was warping the space
got distorted Luffy goes on to help
vagapong and he recognizes Luffy by
saying oh Your Dragon's son right I knew
you would come here he also recognizes
Bonnie and says that she had grown up
next we see that vagapunk begins to
hover and says the boots that they are
all wearing have that same function
after showing them how to hover they all
blast off into the sky and we are
introduced to Dr vegapunk as the chapter
ends now this is definitely the image I
had in mind when it came to the question
of what does vegapunk look like quirky
design and you know the apple on the
head just it killed me for some reason
but that is it for this chapter we found
out some really interesting things such
as you know dragons starting the
Revolutionary Army after the instance on
O'Hara that 20 kingdoms took on the
ancient Kingdom later becoming the world
government and then of course that Saul
is still alive great stuff in this one
and I can't wait to see what comes next
what did you make of this chapter let us
know in the comment section below now if
you enjoyed this video and you'd like to
see more one piece reviews and chapters
don't forget to smash that like button
make this the video you subscribe if you
haven't and hit the notification Bell to
turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one piece chapter reviews
and updates and until the day next
chapter or video drops feel free to
check out our huge and growing one piece
playlist that includes videos on Dragon
an hour long video on Shanks all seven
yonko and much more link to that is in
the description and on screen now thanks
again for having me again this week in
gozen's absence and we can't wait to see
you in the next one till next time my
friends take care peace